this bedroom I mean my son sleep fairly
small living on the lockdown in a
shipping container for this mom and her
11 month old son is not easy with a
decision expected today about whether
the government will extend or ease the
current lockdown restrictions Amelia
like so many others on this estate in
West London is concerned I'm quite
worried about my job because you know if
we don't continue making sales then I'll
be out of work and that's kind of my
main income right now so with a baby
I'll be really odd the economy has been
hit the hardest leaving many facing an
uncertain future we've seen the
challenges that the impact of the
lockdown of poses for people in
communities like this but for the 5.9
million businesses across the country
many are running out of cash and are
struggling to survive
we can't babe in yeah we might have to
shut our doors forever we've been in
business now for 12 years been a
nonprofit organization for the last two
years because the owner of this martial
arts gym does not pay rates directly to
the government it means he doesn't
qualify for support and now he's whoa
Dee's business is on the verge of
collapse in the hands of the gods
of our members and their goodwill
envelopes at the hands of our landlords
whether they need the money and will
request the money for rent which we
can't pay it as kovat 19 continues to
claim lives and ruin livelihoods the
government knows the future of the
country is at stake
no Philips Sky News in West London